[Musique]
chez les élèves vont à ceux qui ont le
bac j'ai avec bonsoir c'est bien c'est
beau ça nous fait six morts et au second
ça veut dire tu vas passer un week-end
de merde désolé pour ceux qui sont au
rattrapage
l'opp à chacun sont légalement en fait
il va en avoir besoin votre pote on va
faire comment nous pour la bagnole vous
êtes d'un bukavu coup je vais devenir
légaux but à sept mois et demi sans quoi
on y va premier arrivé premier servi
si jamais vous les uns dans les autres
on resta longtemps
yum il va se retirer doigts du cul il va
bosser tout le week end sa coque et ce
sont les enfants qui déjà est massé
mouais
[Applaudissements]
bon on y croit les cas la neige
les fonds en euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends tu es sûr que tu cplt ça toi
socrates ne dis pas que la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
dans votre cas j'avais cru comprendre y